the question that i got was what do the
green flags look like how do i identify
better quality women rich okay this is
what we're talking about she takes
ownership for her choices in life next
one i got is you want to make sure that
she doesn't have a large notch count
she's pleasant and doesn't nag you
persistently you want a woman that's
going to encourage and support your
purpose she's got culinary skills she's
tidy and cleans up unprompted and
continues doing so unprompted i got a
kid if my girl doesn't have a good
relationship with her then that's going
to be problematic on a long-term basis
right she's going to use
a smartphone a handheld device
not for attention she's going to use it
to keep in touch with family and friends
obedience obedience is important do you
want a woman that's a compliment to your
life not the focus women if you're
listening to this if you don't like that
you can go find the dorky beta out there
and you can be with that because that's
all you're gonna get top shelf men don't
put up with crap that's just the way
that it is
you